[Music]
hi hello hi we're gathered here today to
play a game called happy wheels I have
to get on a plane in three hours and 35
minutes when I said be ready for
anything I don't think you guys were
expecting this but I am gonna play this
honestly and truly how is it changed
since the last time that I played it not
that much
apparently when was the last time I
played hang on so the last time I played
it was October 2016 which is almost
three years ago now oh wait no um the
the super secret quiet the quietest
let's play I did I did a couple times in
there but it's been a while I actually
did before I started doing highlights I
did one that was acts 6 year master of
balls that's hilarious
so we're gonna play an
honest-to-goodness we're gonna we're
gonna honestly goodness leave we're
honest and we're good in that we are
going to play this game and we're gonna
be honest and good about it when we play
it so put on your honest hats and put on
your good pants because we're about to
play happy wheels yay I'm actually
excited about when I heard the music
kick on I was like oh yeah it's been so
long so I think we can go by top rated
of this month and just see what happens
cuz it's been so long it's been so long
I don't Oh click here click click what
like flick it ok jump crouch I amazingly
stiff like I remember amazingly I
remember wow now this is something
special
I mean it's very impressive but this
isn't exactly game Mario look out it's
very impressive let me let me just say
that straight up it's very impressive on
a technical perspective but it is it's
it's not this isn't fun I don't want to
be rude by real oh yeah I don't want to
be rude about it but oh you're so nice
though you're so I hope you liked it and
have a nice day thanks anonymous
I guess the top rated of this month I
you know I can't fault it I cannot fault
it you know that was not bad shooting
stars music this is my first music level
a music level a music level click on the
Boop oh yeah oh wow
oh I can't leave
[Music]
no no no no what does happy wheels
become what does happen every wheels in
my absence I love it I love it I love it
a lot I can't fault it at all in any way
shape before I cannot fault that I can't
fault it a fat bat lady snatches your
baby in a cave oh you're not lying about
a thing
you were like hey at least I get to play
hey that's pretty good right watch out
all right here we go all right wow this
is great
like I'm not mocking it like honestly
like there's there is a reason why happy
wheels is so popular is because it's
just like it is fun oh hey you killed my
son
um what that's amazing oh [ __ ] okay all
right well made that all right can I get
up here thank you thank you thank you
thank you please thank you thank you at
least I remember how to play amazingly I
remember there's no escape now oh my son
might embed a wire that's really
impressive
I gotta admit they even got the shading
on the eyes the pupils of the eyes have
shading look at this layer that's
amazing this is incredible what happened
to happy wheels what I was away
don't move short oh I love it don't move
oh yeah this is still a classic I'm not
moving I'd never move why would I move
this is all very impressive very very
impressive all right
[Music]
the level of quality of dome moves has
diminished I will just I will just say
that it has diminished Togo fight Oh
rate 5 and nothing will happen seriously
quit it great
hi Tammy bye Timmy bye Billy
mark hey wait a minute Santa [ __ ] I died
time to try because like I find the
physics humors and it is it like it is
well [ __ ] I like it does still have a
charm to it even to this day I'm
laughing because of like all these
memories of like play I've played this
game for how I've played this game for
hundreds of hours and the amazing thing
about is like these things can happen
new that you've never seen before
like alright cool good things can happen
that you've still never seen before it's
just like uh is so surreal like I
thought I'd left this part of me behind
I thought you know when you grow up you
put your child sorry what Oh when you
grow up you put your childish things
away and you you move on and you you
move on with your life and you you you
you get out you get good and you know
everything you know you grow up but you
know to come back to its really I don't
know wholesome I don't think wholesome
is the right word when things like this
are happening but wholesome I'm a-goin
wholesome
my buttocks alright good got that
dislodged all right Santa
take a back foot out how does that
pierce me through the flat of the handle
yeah nope nope oh come on you [ __ ]
get out of here like it's weird it's
like I've been a behavior loop where I
[ __ ] come on I can totally see lay
out every single nook and cranny of me
playing this before I just gotta get oh
no [ __ ] [ __ ] all right come on ah I'm
gonna get you get out of here with that
door oh don't
okay Santa has been disarmed all I must
do is get up here oh yes Billy earmark
for me no Santa don't so it's a standoff
is it hey yah oh my dance on your corpse
big guy no no I didn't really mean I did
talking damn it damn it damn you all
right cool cool cool if this bat F is ax
just back off god [ __ ] I'm alive no I'm
not a life that was Santa oh oh god I
just I thought you know this would be a
fun revisit to happy wheels and I would
just be like what the day to do the
playing a game that I played before and
everything would be fine and
and eat ah are you really trying I am
really trying I am really trying I'm
really trying I'm really trying right
why is it wrapped up I feel like things
didn't necessarily get so trapped to say
that they are now
oh no no no Sean not like this not like
this okay it's okay
Santa just oh no Santa's caught on the
ax in my dick okay there we go there we
go they're good it's gotta get out of
here my poor abused bean okay here we go
they're gonna discuss scooch all right
it's fine there we go I hate nothing all
right that is enough that's enough I am
limited time it's it's fun look that's
the thing it's fun it's weird being back
it's weird playing it again cuz it's
still fun like the levels are hit or
miss but uh you know it's still fun and
to know it's good to know that people
are still making so I am out of time
because I've been so swamped with
post-production on the big project
yada yada I can't say much but it's just
like everyday we have to do a little
something more and then the other day
we're filming pickups and that took all
day and now I have to go to Cincinnati
and I don't want to talk about why I'm
going to Cincinnati but I've just been
very busy
but I'm having fun and at the end of the
day that's what YouTube should be about
is having fun so if that means that I
got to blow my ass up on happy wheels
all over again then I guess I'm happy to
do that so thank you everybody so much
for watching I have done way too many
episodes of happy wheels but it's all in
a playlist so if you want to see more
and you want to see me evolve over the
go check out the playlist link in the
description below thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want me to play
more happy wheels
I don't know shout as loud as you can
the comments tell me down there hey I
don't know maybe see no promises no
promises at all but thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]